Josh likes to go birdwatching at this park in Chicago right by the lake. And generally, he's the youngest person there-- like, by far. He's in his 20s.
乔什喜欢在芝加哥湖边的一个公园里观鸟。他通常是那里最年轻的人——差距相当大。他才20多岁。
Usually, it's older couples. One of the first times that I went there, I spent the majority of the morning with a couple of old ladies trying to find a warbler.
那里通常都是上了年纪的夫妇。我有一次去那里，大部分时间都和几位老太太待在一起，试图寻找一只莺。
That afternoon, he walked around with two old men. And when Josh knelt down to get a better look at a bird, one of the men remarked, I remember when I could do that. You know, kneel down?
那天下午，他和两位老人一起走。当乔什蹲下来以便更清楚地看鸟时，其中一位老人说：“我还记得我能那样做的时候。你知道，蹲下来？”
So that's your scene. Those are your people.
这就是你的圈子。这些人就是你的同类。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
So it was a refreshing change one day last fall when Josh got to the park and a college kid came up to him-- like 18, 19 years old. And they started talking about birds, what Josh had seen that day.
所以，去年秋天的一天，当乔什来到公园，一个大学生——大约18、19岁的样子——走过来和他搭话，这让他感到耳目一新。他们开始聊起鸟，聊乔什那天看到了什么。
And he starts saying things that he had seen, which were really impressive. Basically his whole list was new to me, at that park, at least. He had seen a northern shrike earlier, some longspurs that were flying over, snow buntings, which I hadn't seen ever, actually.
他开始说他见到的一些鸟，真的令人印象深刻。基本上他提到的整个列表对我来说都是新的，至少在那个公园里是这样。他早些时候见过一只灰伯劳，还有一些飞过的角百灵，以及雪鹀，事实上我从未见过。
And this kid is also super knowledgeable, not in a show-offy way. He just knew tons about birds. So it was fun to talk to him. And they decided to walk around the park together. And they head down this path into the trees. So it's like dense, with trees around them on both sides. And the path itself is really narrow, just like two or three feet wide.
这个孩子也非常博学，但并不显摆。他只是知道大量关于鸟类的知识。所以和他聊天很有趣。他们决定一起在公园里走走。他们沿着这条小路走进树林。路两旁长满了树，显得很茂密。小路本身非常狭窄，只有两三英尺宽。
At a certain point, he spots a sparrow. And we get our binoculars on it. And he says, oh, a fox sparrow. And I said, I don't know if that's a fox sparrow. It looks-- the coloration looks right. It's really deep red. But it looks a little too small for me. It looks more like a song sparrow in size.
走到某个地方，他发现了一只麻雀。我们用望远镜观察它。他说：“哦，是一只白冠带鹀。”我说：“我不知道那是不是白冠带鹀。它看起来……颜色确实像。它是深红色的。但对我来说它看起来有点太小了。体型更像是一只歌带鹀。”
And he said, I think I have those.
他说：“我想我有那些。”
I think I have those?
我想我有那些？
He said, I think I have those.
他说：“我想我有那些。”
And then the kid sets down his backpack on the ground. And he opens the front flap. And Josh assumes he's going to take out some photos or something to compare to this bird. But the kid pulls out two little white bags-- or maybe they're envelopes-- reaches inside them--
接着那孩子把背包放在地上。他打开前盖。乔什以为他会拿出一些照片或类似的东西来和这只鸟做对比。但那孩子拿出了两个白色的小袋子——或者可能是信封——伸手进里面——
And just delicately shuffles out two birds on the ground. And sure enough, it's a song sparrow and a fox sparrow.
然后轻柔地在地上摊开了两只鸟。果然，是一只歌带鹀和一只白冠带鹀。
Wait, wait, wait. He opens two bags. And there are two of the exact birds you're talking about in the two bags?
等等，等等。他打开两个袋子。然后你说的两只鸟就正好在两个袋子里？
Right. That's correct.
是的。没错。
Like just dead birds?
是死鸟吗？
Just dead birds. Just the dead birds that we were talking about.
就是死鸟。就是我们刚才讨论的那些死鸟。
The kid apologizes for the smell. Says he found them dead on the ground the day before. They weren't taxidermied or anything, and they were starting to deteriorate. And after placing them on the ground, the college kid looks at the sizes of the two birds and says to Josh, oh, you're right. Like a fox sparrow is bigger than a song sparrow.
那孩子为气味道歉。说他是前一天在地上发现它们死掉的。它们没有做成标本，开始腐烂了。在把它们放在地上后，这个大学生看着两只鸟的体型，对乔什说：“哦，你是对的。白冠带鹀确实比歌带鹀大。”
And then he carefully puts the two birds back into their white envelopes and into the knapsack. And Josh acts like this is the most normal thing in the world when, in fact, he told me this is totally weird. This is not something birders ever do. He has found out since it is actually illegal to have any migratory birds, dead or alive.
然后他小心翼翼地把两只鸟放回白色信封里，塞进背包。乔什表现得好像这是世界上最正常的事情，事实上，他告诉我这完全诡异。这不是观鸟者会做的事。他后来发现，持有任何候鸟，无论死活，实际上都是违法的。
And then they spend four or five hours together that day. And Josh says nothing about it-- asks nothing, never brings it up.
那天他们一起待了四五个小时。乔什对此只字未提——什么也没问，从未提起这件事。
I couldn't envision a scenario in which saying something would lead to a good conclusion.
我无法想象任何一种情况下，说出来会有一个好的结果。
For instance, maybe the kid would think it was intrusive or rude for him to ask. Or maybe the kid was doing something shady.
例如，也许那孩子会认为他问这些是多管闲事或无礼。或者那孩子在做什么阴暗的事。
Might have been not the best thing to ask, isolated behind this hedge. You know?
在树篱后面单独相处时问这些，可能不是最好的主意。你知道吗？
Oh, right. You're, like, alone in some thicket.
哦，对。你们就像是在某个灌木丛里单独待着。
Yes.
是的。
Did you get the feeling like anything could happen? Like, do you feel like if you had asked the wrong question, he would have reached into the bag and pulled out, like, a human ear?
你有种什么事情都可能发生的感觉吗？比如，如果你问了不该问的问题，你会不会觉得他会伸手进包里，然后掏出一只人耳朵之类的东西？
[JOSH LAUGHS]
[乔什笑]
That was what prevented me from asking, yeah.
那就是阻止我询问的原因，没错。
I did talk to the college student. He told me at the time, he didn't know that keeping birds was illegal. But now that he does, he's gotten rid of all of his dead birds. And he asked me not to use his name here on the radio.
我确实和那个大学生谈过了。他告诉我，当时他并不知道私藏鸟类是违法的。但现在他知道了，他已经处理掉了所有的死鸟。他请求我不要在广播里使用他的名字。
He says in all, he picked up maybe 15 or 20 birds. At some point he realized he could just find them near certain buildings with big windows. They would fly into the windows and die. And he didn't see the harm. He had no idea that Josh still wonders about this today.
他说他总共捡到了大约15或20只鸟。有段时间他意识到，他可以在某些有大窗户的建筑附近捡到它们。它们会撞到窗户上死掉。他没觉得这有什么害处。他根本不知道乔什至今还在琢磨这件事。
Yeah, he should have asked me more about it if he wanted to know.
是啊，如果他想知道的话，他应该多问我一点的。
Well, he was a little scared to ask you about it.
嗯，他有点害怕问你这件事。
Mhm.
嗯。
He was scared of what the answer might be.
他害怕答案会是什么。
[COLLEGE KID LAUGHS]
[大学生笑]
Yeah, I guess that really freaked him out. I guess it is kind of gross to be carrying dead birds around in your backpack.
是啊，我想这确实把他吓坏了。我猜在背包里随身携带死鸟确实有点恶心。
And if he'd asked, like, well, what are you going to do with them? What would you have said?
如果他问了，比如，“那你打算拿它们怎么办？”你会怎么回答？
Nothing, really. I just kind of keep them around.
没什么，真的。我只是把它留在身边而已。
See, that's creepy.
你看，这就很恐怖。
[COLLEGE KID LAUGHS]
[大学生笑]
It's interesting to have them to look at closely so you can see things you wouldn't see on birds that are out in the wild.
能近距离观察它们是很有趣的，这样你就能看到在野外鸟类身上看不到的东西。
So all pretty innocent. But Josh didn't know that. In fact, Josh still thinks that he did the right thing not to bring it up with him.
所以这一切都挺无辜的。但乔什不知道。事实上，乔什仍然认为他没提起这件事是做对了。
Like, if-- let's say he had his entire bag full of birds and his car full of birds, and I started asking questions, and he knew what he was doing was illegal. Then it probably wouldn't have been the best idea for me to do that.
比如，如果……假设他整个包里都装满了鸟，车里也装满了鸟，而我开始问问题，他知道他所做的是非法的。那么我这样做可能就不是什么好主意了。
You mean like he's got a gun in that bag, too?
你是说就像他包里还有一把枪吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
And then the next person he sees on the trail, he reaches into the bag, and he pulls out, like, your head.
然后他在小路上看到的下一个人，他伸手进包里，掏出……比如你的头？
My ear? Yeah.
我的耳朵？是啊。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
This is what happens to people who ask questions.
这就是问问题的人会遭遇的下场。
And maybe sometimes too many questions is one. You know?
也许有时候问题问得太多也是一种。你知道吗？
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. A little information can change everything, make something that seems totally menacing totally benign. And the problem is it is not always clear when to disclose that information. In fact, it might not even occur to you to disclose it.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。一点点信息就能改变一切，让看似极具威胁的事情变得完全无害。问题在于，何时公开这些信息并不总是很明确。事实上，你甚至可能根本没想到要公开它。
If you're in the other side, you might not feel like it's your right to ask-- like Josh with this kid. He felt like he didn't know him well enough to pry. Well, today we have stories where people's lives change in amazing, dramatic ways because they decided to disclose or not to disclose certain facts about themselves. Stay with us.
如果你处于另一边，你可能觉得没有权利去问——就像乔什对待那个孩子一样。他觉得他不够了解他，没法深究。嗯，今天我们要讲的故事里，人们的生活因为决定公开或不公开某些关于自己的事实，而发生了奇妙、戏剧性的变化。留下来。
Act One, Full Disclosure. You know, most of us, we basically just keep stuff to ourselves. Right? We withhold information. We do not say everything. You run into an acquaintance on the street, and they ask you, how are you? You generally do not tell them how you are, really. Adult life means we provide information on a need-to-know basis.
第一幕，全面披露。你知道，我们大多数人，基本就是把事情藏在心里。对吧？我们隐瞒信息。我们不会说出一切。你在街上碰到一个熟人，他们问你：“你好吗？”你通常不会真正告诉他们你过得怎么样。成年人的生活意味着我们在有必要时才提供信息。
Your mom asks you on the phone about something you think that the two of you are just going to fight about. Sometimes you dodge, right? You do not talk about things that you don't want to talk about.
你妈妈在电话里问你一些你觉得你们俩只会为此争吵的事情。有时候你会回避，对吧？你不会去谈那些你不想谈的事情。
But what would it be like to not live like that? Well, Michael Leviton knows.
但如果生活不是那样会怎样呢？嗯，迈克尔·莱维顿知道。
I just have a very unusual family. They valued honesty to an extreme extent.
我的家庭非常不寻常。他们把诚实看作一种极端的要求。
Michael's in his 30s, and he was raised by parents who encouraged him and his siblings to tell everything, the whole truth, all the time, believing that it hurts relationships when we avoid awkward truths, that we all should just man up and talk things through. We should work things out.
迈克尔30多岁，他是在鼓励他和兄弟姐妹始终坦诚相待、说出全部真相的父母养大的，他们认为当我们回避尴尬的事实时会伤害关系，我们都应该振作起来把事情谈开。我们应该把事情解决掉。
And being honest also means being true to who you are, right? Which, obviously, anybody wants for their kids. But hearing how far his family went with this, it makes you really understand how incredibly strange your daily life would be if you were to never withhold the truth. Like, for a long time, Michael believed that if somebody asked him a question-- I mean, like, any question at all-- he had to answer it honestly.
而且诚实也意味着忠于自我，对吧？这显然是所有人都希望自己孩子拥有的特质。但听到他的家庭在这方面走得有多远，就能让你真正理解，如果你从不隐瞒真相，你的日常生活会有多么不可思议地怪异。比如，很长一段时间里，迈克尔坚信如果有人问他一个问题——我是说，任何问题——他都必须诚实回答。
This is funny because in job interviews, people would ask me what my biggest flaw was. And I would go into a long rant about all my flaws and all the negative things anyone's ever said about me. And people would look at me-- I got used to this expression of horror. And sometimes it was kind of comic. People would laugh. Like, wow, you thought you had to actually answer that? You're clearly supposed--
这很有趣，因为在求职面试中，人们会问我最大的缺点是什么。我会长篇大论地抱怨我所有的缺点以及别人对我说过的所有负面评价。人们会看着我——我习惯了这种惊恐的表情。有时这还有点滑稽。人们会笑。就像，“哇，你以为你真的必须回答那个？你显然应该……”
That's amazing. That's really amazing. Yeah, you are the only person in the history of job interviews to have ever done that.
那太棒了。真的太棒了。没错，你是求职面试历史上唯一这么做过的人。
Not the only person.
不是唯一一个。
That's true. His brother Josh does the same thing. More on that later. Let's stay with Michael for now.
也对。他弟弟乔什也做同样的事。稍后详述。现在我们先留在迈克尔身上。
OK. One time, I went on a date when I was in college. And I went on this date. And I spent the whole date explaining why she should want to be with me-- you know, what was great about me-- and also why other people didn't want to be with me. I'm saying all the bad things that ever happened to me, why I was rejected by the world.
好。有一次，我上大学时去约会。我去了那次约会。我整个约会过程都在解释为什么她应该想和我在一起——你知道，我身上有什么好的地方——同时也解释为什么其他人不想和我在一起。我说出所有发生在我身上的坏事，为什么我被世界拒绝。
Now, that was just being honest. I was just telling her all the information necessary, in my mind, to decide whether to be with me. I thought it was my responsibility as a person on a date to explain everything they were dealing with from the first moment of the date so that they could make an informed decision about how to move forward.
现在，那只是诚实。在我看来，我只是在告诉她所有必要的决策信息，让她决定是否要和我在一起。我认为作为一个约会对象，我有责任在约会的第一刻就解释清楚他们面对的是什么，这样他们才能在前进的道路上做出明智的决定。
That's what I love about this story, is that you thought you were doing a good job. You thought you were acing the date.
这就是我喜欢这个故事的地方，你以为你做得很好。你以为你让约会非常成功。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
For a long time, if Michael decided that he didn't want to hang out with somebody anymore, he would just, you know, come out and say it-- let's not be friends. When he would go and hear musician buddies of his perform, they would ask him afterwards, how'd you like the show? He would do the thing that nobody ever does. He would actually tell them, you know, the arrangements could have been better. You shouldn't play with this band. That first number should be in double time.
很长一段时间里，如果迈克尔决定不再和某人来往，他就会……你知道，直接说出来——我们别做朋友了吧。当他去听音乐伙伴表演时，他们结束后会问他：“你觉得表演怎么样？”他会做那个没人会做的事。他会直接告诉他们，你知道，编曲本可以更好。你不应该和这支乐队一起演奏。第一首歌应该用双倍速度。
If somebody told Michael about a TV show that they liked, or really if they expressed any opinion at all on any subject-- like they told him they loved chocolate-- he could not help himself from offering his own opinion, forcefully. He hates chocolate.
如果有人告诉迈克尔他们喜欢的电视节目，或者实际上他们对任何主题表达了任何观点——比如他们告诉他他们喜欢巧克力——他无法控制自己，会强有力地提出自己的观点。他讨厌巧克力。
And they would see it as, why would this person say this thing? Why would this person trash something I love so immediately? They must just be doing it as an act of aggression.
而他们会认为，“为什么这个人要这么说？为什么这个人会如此直接地抨击我喜欢的东西？他一定只是在表现出攻击性。”
But really, it was more a gut instinct from my childhood, that conversation was expressing whatever was going on.
但实际上，这更多是我童年时期的一种直觉，对话就是表达正在发生的事情。
In other words, you expressed your honest feelings about chocolate. Now it's my turn to express my honest feelings about chocolate.
换句话说，你表达了关于巧克力的诚实感受。现在轮到我表达关于巧克力的诚实感受了。
Yeah.
是的。
But would you do things, like, you would perceive, in a conversation with somebody you just met, oh, this person's kind of bossy. And then would you say, like, you know, I think you're very bossy?
但你会做一些……比如，你在和刚认识的人对话时会感觉到，“这个人有点爱发号施令。”然后你会说，比如，“你知道，我觉得你非常爱发号施令。”吗？
A lot of the time, things like that would happen. Yeah. A lot of time, I would feel like it was my job to observe things and to tell people how they were and go like, oh, it's funny. You know, you do this thing.
很多时候，这样的事情会发生。是的。很多时候，我觉得观察事物并告诉人们他们是什么样的人是我的工作，就像，“哦，这很有趣。你知道，你做了这件事。”
And I wouldn't notice that it was triggering to people to say something like that, to go, oh, you notice you're very controlling? Have you noticed that? Like, why are you like that? And I would ask these questions that would lead in horrible directions all the time.
而我不会注意到说这样的话会刺激到别人，去说，“哦，你注意到你非常控制欲强吗？你注意到了吗？比如，为什么你是这样？”我会问这些导致可怕后果的问题，一直都是这样。
See, I think all of us have met people who will say, well, I just tell it how it is. And people don't like to hear the truth. And I think most of us just feel like, well, that person is just an asshole or just has something wrong with them, that they don't give a damn about other people's feelings.
看，我认为我们所有人都见过那些会说“我只是实话实说”的人。人们不喜欢听到真相。而我想我们大多数人只是觉得，好吧，那个人要么就是混蛋，要么就是有什么问题，他不顾及别人的感受。
And what you're saying is somehow you learned this as a kind of, like, strategy for dealing with the world from the start.
而你所说的是，不知何故，你从一开始就学会了这种作为应对世界的策略。
Yeah. And to me, it was kind of like an exciting conversational thing to do, to be like, let's talk about ourselves. Everyone's having these small-talk conversations. They're so pointless and boring. Really, we should get to the real stuff immediately.
是的。对我来说，这就像是一种令人兴奋的对话方式，就像，“让我们谈谈我们自己吧。”每个人都在进行这种琐碎的闲聊。它们毫无意义且无聊。真的，我们应该立即切入正题。
This is so interesting. I'm learning about you. And it'll be much more real and interesting.
这太有趣了。我正在了解你。而且这会更真实、更有趣。
You know, which in a way is so idealistic. Think about for a second all the people pleasers who will say anything in a conversation just to kind of get by, all the folks who spend years in therapy getting the courage to tell people what they really think.
你知道，从某种程度上说这太理想主义了。试着想一想所有那些唯唯诺诺的人，他们在对话中什么都说只是为了混过去，所有那些花多年时间在心理治疗中获得勇气去告诉别人他们真实想法的人。
Speaking for myself, I feel like I don't even know what I think half the time or what I believe. And I have lots of conversations where I know what I believe, and I don't say it because I don't want to have conflict. I want to avoid conflict. And I think that lots of us are like that.
以我自己为例，我甚至觉得我有一半时间不知道自己在想什么或相信什么。我有很多次对话，我知道自己在相信什么，但我没说出来，因为我不想有冲突。我想避免冲突。我认为我们很多人都是那样。
Not Michael. His parents taught him, be stronger than that.
迈克尔不是。他的父母教他，要比那更强大。
I don't know what Michael talked to you about.
我不知道迈克尔跟你谈了什么。
This is Michael's dad, Mark. Everybody says that he was brutally honest when his kids were growing up. He made his living in the music business. And all of his life he has also worked, appropriately enough, as a professional critic. Michael's mom is a therapist who will tell you straight out--
这是迈克尔的父亲，马克。每个人都说他在孩子成长过程中非常残酷地诚实。他以音乐行业为生。他这一辈子也一直适当地兼职做职业评论员。迈克尔的妈妈是一位会直言不讳的心理学家——
I just can't lie.
我只是不能撒谎。
But Michael's dad told me he looks back on his kids' childhoods with a lot of regret for just how harshly he would tell everybody the truth all the time, as he saw it, and especially for how frank he was about things with his own kids.
但迈克尔的爸爸告诉我，他回顾孩子们的童年时充满了遗憾，遗憾于他总是以自己所见的那样严厉地告诉所有人真相，尤其是他对自己的孩子们是多么直率。
From my point of view, some of my part was not very age appropriate, let's say. We kind of revealed to the children information about our marriage that most parents, I don't think, would reveal. And more or less left the kids to deal with it.
从我的角度来看，我的一部分行为非常不适龄，我们可以这么说。我们向孩子们揭露了关于我们婚姻的信息，我认为大多数父母不会揭露这些。而且基本上就让孩子们自己去应对。
Michael had told me about this. There were a few stories of parental over-sharing. But the one that I think captured just how disturbingly far this could go sometimes happened while his parents were splitting up. His parents divorced when he and his siblings were teenagers.
迈克尔跟我说过这个。有几个关于父母过度分享的故事。但我认为捕捉到这有时能走多远的一个故事，发生在他们父母分居的时候。他的父母在他和兄弟姐妹十几岁时离婚了。
And every year back then, the family would go to a place I was really surprised to hear exists at all-- family therapy camp, where counseling sessions were done in public throughout the day in front of other people. And so they're at this camp, and their parents are having troubles. And in front of other families and therapists and also in front of their own children-- aged 13, 16, and 19-- Michael's parents hashed out their issues.
当时每年，家里都会去一个我真的很惊讶居然存在的地方——家庭治疗营，咨询会全天在公共场合在其他人面前进行。所以他们在那个营地，他们的父母正在闹矛盾。在其他家庭、治疗师面前，也在他们自己的孩子——13岁、16岁和19岁——面前，迈克尔的父母解决他们的问题。
So, for instance, I remember one therapy session that my mother did that was all about how she felt being married to my dad. About feeling invisible, about these kinds of-- talking about very intense, personal-- like her despair and the things that she dealt with in that marriage.
所以，举例来说，我记得我母亲做过一次治疗会议，全程都在讲她作为我父亲妻子的感受。关于感到被无视，关于这些……谈论非常强烈、私人的……比如她的绝望以及她在婚姻中面对的事情。
And also, I got to see the man my mother was leaving my father for. They would all be there and talk about their feelings towards each other, talk about what had happened, talk about the grievances they had with each other, fights. They would yell at each other and accuse each other of things and kind of air dirt about what the other had done. And it was all in front of us.
而且，我还要去看我母亲离开我父亲时选中的那个男人。他们都会在那里，谈论他们对彼此的感情，谈论发生了什么，谈论他们对彼此的不满，争吵。他们会互相大喊大叫，指责对方做了什么，并互相兜售对方做过的烂事。这一切都在我们面前发生。
But did the parents understand like, oh, that was a problem?
但父母是否意识到，哦，那是个问题？
I don't think so. I think that they, at the time, were very much like, we are speaking our truth. The kids should know what happened. And these are our feelings. And they can just imagine it, but it'd be better if they actually knew what was going on and they knew how we felt.
我不这么认为。我觉得他们当时非常倾向于认为，“我们在说出我们的真相。孩子们应该知道发生了什么。这是我们的感受。他们可以想象，但如果他们确实知道发生了什么、知道我们的感受，会更好。”
Just to be clear, at the time, Michael agreed with this.
明确一下，当时，迈克尔同意这一点。
I was like, oh, this is great. This is how it should be. This is the honest way to deal with it. Everyone else would just hide their divorces, the cowards. They would deal with their divorce in private. And it would be very safe for everyone. But it was actually a lie. The kids wouldn't really know what was going on with their parents.
我就像，“哦，这太棒了。这才是应该有的样子。这是处理这件事诚实的方式。”其他人只会隐藏他们的离婚，胆小鬼。他们会在私下里处理离婚。而且这对每个人都很安全。但这实际上是一个谎言。孩子们不会真正知道他们的父母发生了什么。
So you felt, actually, superior to others.
所以你甚至感到比别人优越。
That was a big part of it, I think, that other people are cowards. And they're very weak. And they can't handle the truth. And they're afraid to express who they really are. They're inauthentic out of fear. And we are actually bravely being authentic, expressing how we really feel and not hiding things.
那是很大一部分原因，我想，其他人是胆小鬼。他们非常软弱。他们无法承受真相。他们害怕表达他们真实的样子。他们因为恐惧而不真实。而我们实际上是在勇敢地做真实的自己，表达我们真正的感受，不隐藏事情。
So these three children grow up like this. And they head out into the world as adults. And they had to confront the fact that these are not the rules that the rest of us are playing under. And the dad says that he knows that he trained them to live in a world that does not exist, a world where people are way more frank with each other than we really are.
所以这三个孩子就这样长大了。他们作为成年人进入了这个世界。他们不得不面对这样一个事实：这并不是我们其他人所遵循的规则。而父亲说他知道他训练他们去生活在一个不存在的世界里，一个人们比我们真实状态要坦诚得多的世界。
Look, how do you create the world that should exist except by acting as if? Acting the way you want to to make the world through your own actions?
听着，除了通过行动来创造那个应该存在的世界，还有什么方法呢？按照你想要的方式行动，通过你自己的行动来塑造世界？
Three siblings are now in their 20s and 30s. And being honest has meant different things to each of them. For Michael's sister Miriam, it's been the easiest. She said she knows that she is not somebody that anybody would ever tell a secret to. And there are times she can't help herself from saying the truth.
三个兄弟姐妹现在都20多岁和30多岁了。而保持诚实对他们每个人来说意义不同。对于迈克尔的妹妹米里亚姆来说，这是最容易的。她说她知道她不是那种任何人会跟她说秘密的人。有时候她无法控制自己说出真相。
Sometimes, like, in work meetings, I'll disagree with something. And then I think, why did I say that?
有时候，比如在工作会议上，我会不同意某件事。然后我会想，为什么我要说那个？
But it's manageable, she says. No bad consequences. Michael's brother Josh is also still a believer, which is remarkable considering the one big life-changing way that this level of honesty has affected him. He trained for seven years to work in law enforcement, to be one of those experts who analyzes crime scenes and figures out what kind of gun was used and the bullet trajectories and all that stuff. He has a master's degree in forensic ballistics.
但她说，这是可以掌控的。没有坏后果。迈克尔的弟弟乔什也是个信徒，考虑到这种诚实程度对他产生的一次重大、改变人生的影响，这就很了不起了。他接受了七年的执法培训，成为那些分析犯罪现场、搞清楚使用了什么枪、子弹轨迹之类的专家之一。他拥有法医弹道学的硕士学位。
But he doesn't have a job doing this because when he's asked about his drug use in job interviews, he always admits that in 1997, when he was 14 years old, he tried mushrooms one time.
但他没有从事这份工作，因为当他在工作面试中被问及毒品使用情况时，他总是承认在1997年，他14岁时，尝试过一次蘑菇。
People always just ask me, well, why did you tell them about that? Is there a record of it? And no, there's not a record of anything. But I feel like I have to tell the truth. I just never thought about lying, even. I didn't even consider it.
人们总是问我：“好吧，为什么你要告诉他们那个？有记录吗？”并没有，没有任何记录。但我感觉我必须说实话。我甚至从未想过撒谎。我甚至没考虑过。
And it seems like everybody's saying that it is OK to lie in certain circumstances because everybody else does. I kind of look at it like in sports. It's kind of saying, these athletes that take steroids, they have to do it because everybody takes steroids in order to compete. And I kind of want to succeed without taking steroids, even in a world that takes steroids, if that makes sense.
看起来每个人都说在某些情况下撒谎是可以的，因为其他人也都这么做。我有点像看待体育运动一样看待它。就像是说，那些使用类固醇的运动员，他们必须这样做，因为为了竞争每个人都使用类固醇。而我有点想在不使用类固醇的情况下成功，即使在一个使用类固醇的世界里，如果这说得通的话。
Michael, meanwhile, seems to have had a much harder time than either of his siblings when it comes to honesty. By the time he was in his late 20s, Michael had noticed that acting exactly the way that he thought a principled person should be acting, he was constantly getting in all these awful clashes with people-- like, all the time. And it was confusing. And he didn't like it.
与此同时，迈克尔在谈到诚实时，似乎比他的兄弟姐妹中的任何一个都要困难得多。到他20多岁末期，迈克尔注意到他表现得完全像他认为一个有原则的人应该表现的那样，他不断地与人发生这些可怕的冲突——一直都是这样。这令人困惑。而他不喜欢这样。
And the part of his life where it was especially vexing was dating. Over and over, he would meet somebody he really liked, go out on a date, and then they'd never want to see him again. And he had no idea what he did.
而他生活中特别令人烦恼的部分就是约会。一次又一次，他会遇到他非常喜欢的人，去约会，然后他们就再也不想见他了。他根本不知道他做了什么。
Well, that's the hard thing about dating. It's hard to learn when you're dating because people don't tell you what you did wrong. You don't know why you were rejected. You have to figure it out yourself.
嗯，这就是约会困难的地方。当你约会时很难学习，因为人们不会告诉你你哪里做错了。你不知道为什么你被拒绝了。你必须自己想出来。
And that's why a lot of dating is a very hard thing to improve. It's really hard to improve your dating because-- like, this is the thing that's famous. If you're a bad kisser, does anyone say, by the way, you're a bad kisser. Here's how to kiss better?
这就是为什么很多约会是非常难提升的事情。很难提升你的约会技巧，因为……比如，这是很有名的。如果你是一个糟糕的接吻者，有人会说：“顺便说一句，你接吻很烂。这里是接吻得更好的方法。”吗？
They just never kiss you again.
他们只是再也不吻你了。
It's not their responsibility. They never kiss you again.
这不是他们的责任。他们再也不吻你了。
Right.
没错。
And you don't know why you were rejected. It could've been anything. You just have to have your paranoid fantasy of all the millions of things that you think you did wrong. But it could've been anything. Dating's chaos in that way.
而你不知道为什么你被拒绝。可能是任何原因。你只能陷入对自己所做的所有数百万件你认为做错的事情的偏执幻想中。但可能是任何事。约会在那方面就是混乱的。
Even when he had dates that for a while seemed to be going OK, he would blurt out something honest, out of habit, and ruin them.
即使当他有几次看起来进展还不错的约会时，他也会出于习惯脱口而出一些诚实的话，毁掉它们。
If anything beautiful or cool happens, I would stop everything and go, wasn't that an amazing moment? Let's just stop and, like, talk about how amazing that was. That barely ever happens.
如果发生了什么美好或酷的事情，我会停下一切说：“那不是一个很棒的时刻吗？让我们停下来，谈谈它有多么棒。”那几乎从未发生过。
And a lot of the time, the moment would be ruined by my commenting on it.
而且很多时候，那个时刻会被我的评论毁掉。
Like what kind of moment are you talking about?
比如你说的什么时刻？
Well, OK. For instance, one time I was walking with this woman. And I was having this date that was going well. And she put a cigarette in her mouth to smoke it. And I grabbed the cigarette out of her mouth and kissed her. And it was great.
好吧，好。举个例子，有一次我和这个女人走在一起。我进行的这次约会进展顺利。她把一支烟放在嘴里准备抽。我从她嘴里抓过烟，吻了她。那很棒。
And then she stepped away. And we finished this kiss. And I said, wow. That's not something I usually do. That was really amazing. I was actually very inspired there. Usually, I'm just so awkward. And actually, that was much-- and I just ruined the whole thing. There was no reason for me to comment on how cool I had just been.
然后她退后一步。我们结束了这个吻。我说：“哇。这不是我通常会做的事情。那真的很棒。我当时确实受到了很大的启发。通常，我只是那么尴尬。而且实际上，那比……”然后我就毁了整件事。我没有理由评论我刚刚有多酷。
Well, I think the key word there was "usually." I think "usually" kind of kills that moment.
嗯，我认为那里的关键词是“通常”。我觉得“通常”有点扼杀了那个时刻。
Oh, yeah. Well, that's actually another thing here. It was my tendency to talk about my general dating experience and to talk about those things just because they were on my mind. When I was on a date, I was naturally thinking about other dates and other things that had happened. So I would say, oh yeah. I've done a couple other amazing things on dates like that. I would just start saying these things, and it would ruin everything.
哦，是的。好吧，实际上这里还有另一件事。我倾向于谈论我一般的约会经历，谈论那些事情只是因为它们在我的脑海里。当我在约会时，我自然会想到其他的约会以及曾经发生过的其他事情。所以我就会说，“哦，是的。我在约会上还做过几次其他类似那样很棒的事情。”我就会开始说这些事情，然后它就会毁掉一切。
I feel like when you tell some of these stories, you're like somebody from another planet or something who got dropped into our world.
我觉得当你讲这些故事时，你就像是一个来自另一个星球的人或者什么，掉进了我们的世界里。
That's what it felt like. I was in the wrong world. And I didn't understand the concept of politeness. When I read-- I actually, at one point around the same time, read a politeness book. I actually read an etiquette book trying to figure it out. And it was just one advice-- every time, it was just lie, lie, lie.
那是我的感觉。我在错误的世界里。我不懂礼貌的概念。当我读……我实际上在同一时间读了一本礼仪书。我实际上读了一本礼节书试图弄明白它。而它只有一个建议——每一次，它只是撒谎，撒谎，撒谎。
It was just, oh, here's a situation-- you don't know someone's name? Lie. Here's a situation-- someone's gone through something horrible? Just lie. Here's another situation. It was just--
它只是，哦，这有一个情况——你不认识某人的名字？撒谎。这有一个情况——某人经历了可怕的事情？只是撒谎。这是另一个情况。它只是……
Right. It didn't say on the page "lie."
对。书上没写“撒谎”。
No, it didn't say to lie. But every piece of advice looked like--
不，它没说要撒谎。但每一条建议看起来都像……
That's what it came down to.
这就是结论。
And it was all about other people's feelings.
而且这一切都是关于别人的感受。
And at some point it occurred to Michael that honesty was coming in the way of noticing other people's feelings. And maybe he needed to change that. And so finally, at 29-- that's five years ago-- he decided he'd had enough, and he started experimenting on his dates with how he acted. Now, these were not complicated experiments by any means. He'd simply have something honest that would occur to him that he wanted to say, and he would not say it.
在某个时候，迈克尔意识到诚实正在阻碍注意到别人的感受。也许他需要改变这一点。所以终于，在29岁——也就是五年前——他决定受够了，他开始在约会中实验他的行为方式。现在，这些绝不是复杂的实验。他只是会想到一些他想说的诚实的话，然后他不说了。
I saw in a very visceral way how I could change my behavior and it would go over better. And I could actually have a great time if I just shut up about certain things. I actually made a list of things not to talk about.
我以一种非常直观的方式看到了我如何能改变我的行为，而且效果会更好。如果我只是闭嘴不谈某些事情，我实际上可以过得很愉快。我实际上列了一张不要谈论的事情清单。
You made a list of things not to talk about?
你列了一张不要谈论的事情清单？
An actual written list of things not to talk about.
一张实际写下来的不要谈论的事情清单。
Do you still have that list?
你还有那张清单吗？
I actually do. Yeah. I add to it sometimes still because it's hard for me to remember. I have to concentrate very hard to not follow my gut instinct to tell the whole truth about things.
我确实有。是的。我有时还会添加进去，因为我很难记住。我必须非常集中精神才能不听从我那种说出全部真相的直觉。
On that list-- you don't have to give an opinion. You don't have to say things out loud. Just because they're true is not helpful. You can choose not to answer a question. Don't fully explain. Make it quick. Say you'll tell them later. End the conversation first. Don't try to impress.
在那张清单上——你不必给出观点。你不必大声说出来。仅仅因为它们是真的并不意味着有帮助。你可以选择不回答问题。不要完全解释。快一点。说你以后会告诉他们。先结束对话。不要试图打动人。
One actually really good one was to stop explicitly describing myself in any way, positive or negative. That I didn't have to say, oh, I'm this kind of person. I do this.
其中一个真正好的建议是停止以任何方式明确描述自己，无论是正面的还是负面的。我不必说，“哦，我是这种人。我做这个。”
Why would that come up at all in a conversation? It would be like, I'm the sort of person who-- why would you be saying that?
为什么在对话中会出现这种情况？这就像，“我是那种……”为什么你会说那个？
Because I believed that's what conversation was. And they couldn't see those things. I didn't understand that they could see those things in your behavior, that they would read behind what you said and learn things. You had to say it explicitly. Otherwise, you were misleading them.
因为我相信那就是对话的内容。而他们看不见那些事情。我不明白他们可以在你的行为中看到那些事情，他们会读懂你所说的话背后的含义，并了解事情。你必须明确说出来。否则，你就是在误导他们。
OK. Next one?
好的。下一个？
At one point, I resolved that if I didn't recognize someone or I didn't remember their name to just pretend I did, which is something-- I used to always go, oh, I don't recognize you. Or, oh, we've met before? I don't remember. Or, I don't remember your name. I realized that I could pretend to know someone's name while I figured out what their name was. And that changed so much.
有一次，我下定决心，如果我不认识某人或者我不记得他们的名字，就假装我认识，这是某件事……我过去总是说，“哦，我不认识你。”或者，“哦，我们见过面吗？我不记得了。”或者，“我不记得你的名字。”我意识到我可以假装知道某人的名字，同时我想办法弄明白他们叫什么名字。而那改变了很多。
One year his New Year's resolutions, typed out, were, quote, "tell no one about my problems. Listen to how others feel instead of telling them how I feel. Pretend more and people please. Remember to make others feel like I find them smart and cool. Act like I agree."
有一年他的新年决心，打字打出来的是，引用：“谁也不要告诉我的问题。听听别人怎么感受，而不是告诉他们我怎么感受。多一点伪装，去讨好别人。记得让别人觉得我发现他们很聪明、很酷。表现得像我同意。”
On the same page-- quote, "my list of things that I am not allowed to talk about-- ideological commentary, unnecessary brutal truths, triggering questions and unwanted inquiries. Avoid asking people what they mean when they use certain words." Or there's this one--
在同一页上——引用，“我的不允许谈论的事情清单——意识形态评论，不必要的残酷真相，触发性问题和不想要的探究。避免在人们使用某些词语时问他们是什么意思。”或者还有这个——
OK. So I wrote here, "Take nothing at face value. Don't investigate things people say. Remember their minds are chaos."
好的。所以我在这里写道，“不要相信任何表面价值。不要调查人们说的话。记住他们的头脑是混乱的。”
Wait, what do you mean by that?
等等，你是什么意思？
I know. It's a strange, strange thing to say. What I meant was that people-- I was of the mindset that other people were saying what they meant. And I would sometimes get into ideological battles with people who hadn't even really been thinking very hard about what they'd said. Because I would say, well, do you really mean that? I mean, what do you mean when you say that? And I would investigate it further. And it would become this attack, when really they didn't mean--
我知道。这是一个奇怪、奇怪的说法。我的意思是人们……我是那种认为别人说的就是他们心里想的人。我有时会和甚至没有认真思考过他们所说的话的人进行意识形态斗争。因为我会说，“好吧，你真的那样认为吗？我是说，当你那么说时你是什么意思？”我会进一步调查。而这会变成一种攻击，当实际上他们并没有打算……
They didn't mean anything.
他们并没有打算什么。
They didn't mean anything by it. They were just saying things they thought were socially acceptable kind of conversations that I would agree with. But then it would devolve into this horrible discussion. And a lot of time, I would get kind of angry. And sometimes, they would say, you know, it's like I don't really mean anything by it. Like they would start to backtrack because they hadn't ever meant it in the first place.
他们并没有打算什么。他们只是说了一些他们认为在社交上可以接受的谈话方式，我会同意。但随后它会演变成这种可怕的讨论。而且很多时候，我会变得有点生气。有时，他们会说，“你知道，就像我并不是那个意思。”就像他们会开始退缩，因为他们最初就根本不是那个意思。
"Remember their minds are chaos"?
“记住他们的头脑是混乱的”？
Yeah, meaning that there's lots of stuff going on that leads to why people say what they say and that I can't know what those things are. That their minds are chaos of feelings, that they're human beings.
是的，意思是说有很多事情在发生，导致了人们为什么说出他们说的话，而我无法知道那些事情是什么。他们的头脑是感受的混乱，他们是人类。
What was kind of inspiring talking to Michael is that although he seemed like somebody who'd dropped into our world without a clue about how the rest of us behave, he then made a study of why he was failing. And he came to conclusions on his own. And he made up this to-do list. And then, like a scientist in a science fiction film who brews up a miracle elixir in the lab and then decides that he should be one to try it first, Michael has put his theories into action.
和迈克尔交谈令人鼓舞的一点是，虽然他看起来像是那种毫无头绪掉进我们世界、不知道我们其他人如何表现的人，但他随后研究了为什么他会失败。他自己得出了结论。他列出了这个待办事项清单。然后，就像科幻电影中那个在实验室里熬制出奇迹药水、然后决定自己应该第一个尝试的科学家一样，迈克尔把他的理论付诸行动了。
And it's working. He's had girlfriends. Last November, he married one of those girlfriends. And so these days, when he's being, like, super-honest in some inappropriate situation, his wife will say to him, wow. That was an interesting way to handle that. Or wow, we're doing that now?
而且这行得通。他交了女朋友。去年11月，他娶了其中一个女朋友。所以这些天，当他在某种不合适的场合表现得太诚实时，他的妻子会对他讲：“哇。那处理它的方式很有趣。”或者，“哇，我们现在做那个？”
He says he still has a way to go with all this stuff. But what he's concluded after this lifelong experiment in honesty is that honesty is not enough. You have to read people for signs that they do not need or do not want to hear the entire truth. And in fact, the whole idea of a world where everybody is honest all the time?
他说他在所有这些事情上还有很长的路要走。但他在这场终生的诚实实验后得出的结论是，诚实是不够的。你必须观察人们是否有不需要或不想听到全部真相的迹象。事实上，整个世界每个人都一直诚实的想法？
It was almost a world where people didn't have feelings. The idea that someone would be upset-- that they weren't supposed to get upset. They were supposed to just hear what I said and go, oh, wow. OK. That's cool. You were honest. I value that.
那几乎是一个人们没有感受的世界。有人会心烦意乱的想法——他们不应该心烦意乱。他们应该只是听我说什么然后说，“哦，哇。好的。那很酷。你很诚实。我重视那个。”
In the real world, Michael says, people have all kinds of feelings swirling around in their heads and insecurities and struggles. What they say may or may not be what they believe. And he says, that's great. That's normal. It's chaos.
在现实世界中，迈克尔说，人们头脑中盘旋着各种各样的感受、不安全感和挣扎。他们说的话可能确实是他们相信的，也可能不是。他说，那太棒了。那是正常的。那是混乱。
Coming up-- lying your way through college. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来——在大学里撒谎度日。就在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different stories on that theme. Today's program-- "Need to Know Basis," stories of people withholding information in a way that has life-changing consequences. We have arrived at act two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目每周当然会选择一个主题，给你们带来关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目——“有必要时才披露”，关于人们以产生改变人生的后果的方式隐瞒信息的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Total Eclipse of the Son. That's son, S-O-N. Stay with me. That's going to make sense later. So the United States has a surprisingly high college dropout rate, particularly at community colleges, where only a third of all first-time students have their two-year degree by the end of three years.
第二幕，儿子的日食。是儿子（son），S-O-N。留下来。稍后这会变得有意义。所以美国有着惊人的高大学辍学率，尤其是在社区大学，只有三分之一的所有首次入学的学生在三年结束时拥有他们的两年制学位。
Community colleges, by the way, are a huge number of students. Almost half of all American college students are in community college. We've done a bunch of stories about college dropouts on our show, most recently a couple weeks ago. Apparently, the first year is the key make-or-break time for whether or not somebody's going to drop out.
顺便说一句，社区大学有着庞大的学生数量。几乎一半的美国大学生都在社区大学。我们在我们的节目中做过很多关于大学辍学的故事，最近的是几周前。显然，第一年是某人是否会辍学的关键时刻。
Zoe Chace spent last fall on the campus of a community college in the South Bronx, Hostos Community College, reporting on what kids need to not drop out.
佐伊·查斯在去年秋天南布朗克斯的社区大学，霍斯托斯社区大学的校园里，报道孩子们需要什么才不会辍学。
I was looking for that one student in the one and three, the kid who succeeds. As soon as I saw Demetrius at the freshman orientation, I thought, oh, there he is-- the success. Front row, always raising his hand, volunteering for the skits. And when I talked to him, he assured me. I had found the right person.
我一直在寻找那一个三个人里的那个学生，那个成功者。当我在新生迎新会上见到德米特里厄斯时，我想，“哦，就是他——成功者。”前排，总是举手，自愿参加短剧。当我跟他交谈时，他向我保证。我找到了对的人。
If there is it valedictorian spot available, that is what I am trying to get.
如果有一个告别演说的位置，那正是我要争取的东西。
That's your spot.
那是你的位置。
Yeah. And if someone somehow beats me out and becomes valedictorian, then I should at least be salutatorian. If someone somehow pulls that off, hats off to them. Truly, they're moving on to do great things.
是的。如果有人不知怎么打败我并成为了告别演讲者，那么我至少应该是优等生代表。如果有人不知怎么做到了，向他们脱帽致敬。真的，他们正在前进并做伟大的事情。
I thought if I spent time with him, I could see what he's doing right. He looks like the one in three. Because Demetrius has two things that are really hard to come by-- extremely high expectations for himself and complete confidence that he will meet or surpass those expectations.
我想如果我和他待在一起，我能看出他哪里做对了。他看起来像是那三个里的那个。因为德米特里厄斯有两样东西，这非常难得——对自己极高的期望，以及完全相信他会达到或超越这些期望。
Throughout my whole life, I try at something, not only do I get it, I usually, like, sweep it. Like I'm vastly superior to most if I try at something. I feel like I could have been a great wrestler. I'm-- damn, I could have been one of the best wrestlers anybody's ever seen.
在我的一生中，我尝试某件事，我不但得到它，我通常还……就像席卷它。我感觉如果我尝试某件事，我远比大多数人优越。我觉得我本可以成为一名伟大的摔跤手。我……该死，我本可以成为任何人见过的最好的摔跤手之一。
Doesn't matter what it is. Demetrius is always about to be a star. From the back, Demetrius is a grown man-- tall and broad-shouldered in a leather coat. From the front, he's still a teenager-- round, freckly baby face, 18 years old. His plan is to get his associates, transfer to a four-year school, major in video game design, and then become one of the best video game designers the world has ever seen.
是什么不重要。德米特里厄斯总是快要成为明星了。从背后看，德米特里厄斯是个成年人——穿着皮大衣，高大宽肩。从正面看，他还是个少年——圆圆的、满是雀斑的娃娃脸，18岁。他的计划是拿到他的副学士学位，转到四年制学校，主修视频游戏设计，然后成为世界上见过的最好的视频游戏设计师之一。
Demetrius tells me he has not always done the work to match his high expectations. In high school, he says he did not always do his work. But this year, he's serious.
德米特里厄斯告诉我他并不总是做能匹配他高期望的工作。在高中，他说他并不总是完成他的工作。但今年，他是认真的。
I haven't let, like, more than three hours pass yet of me getting an assignment and finishing it. If it's possible for me to finish the assignment within the three hours of me receiving that assignment, then I'm going to finish it. I simply can't allow myself to get behind. I got to be active. I got to make sure I get this done. And truth be told, I fully expect that I'm going to have one of the highest GPAs in this school.
我还没让，比如，超过三个小时过去我还没完成 assignment。如果可能的话，我可以在我收到作业后的三个小时内完成，那么我就要完成它。我根本无法允许自己落后。我必须积极。我必须确保我完成它。而且说实话，我完全期望我将拥有这所学校最高的GPA之一。
So I started following Demetrius around, talking with him. I went to his classes, the computer lab, met his girlfriend. He's in love. One day, after months of this, at the end of the semester, we went to a meeting at the school with someone called a success coach.
所以我开始跟踪德米特里厄斯，和他谈话。我去了他的课、计算机实验室，认识了他的女朋友。他正在恋爱。几个月后的某天，在学期末，我们去学校和一位被称为成功教练的人开了个会。
All right. So let's just go over each class and just--
好了。所以让我们过一遍每门课，只是……
Regardless of your GPA, every incoming freshman at Hostos is assigned a success coach, someone to keep them on target. It's different from an adviser in that the success coach is more of a full-time catcher in the rye, someone who tracks their progress through the school year and, if they're falling behind to figure out why and try to fix it; someone to help them pick their classes each semester so they graduate on time, which is why we are here right now.
无论你的GPA如何，霍斯托斯的每位入学新生都被分配了一位成功教练，有人盯着他们保持目标。它和顾问不同，因为成功教练更像是一个全职的《麦田里的守望者》，有人跟踪他们在学年里的进度，如果他们落后了，搞清楚为什么并试图修正它；有人帮助他们每学期选课，这样他们就能按时毕业，这就是我们现在在这里的原因。
I'm here to see if my advisor can help me get into an honors English class because I've gotten all A's all semester. So--
我在这里看看我的顾问是否能帮我进入荣誉英语班，因为我整个学期都得了全A。所以……
Straight A's all semester, as promised. So we sit down with Ray Cartagena, Demetrius's coach. He's in Navy Reserves, huge arms, tattoos. He makes Demetrius look little. How you doing? Straight A's. What do I need to fulfill my requirements? They lean over the computer together and look at his schedule.
正如承诺的，整个学期全A。所以我们和雷·卡塔赫纳坐在一起，德米特里厄斯的教练。他在海军预备役，强壮的胳膊，纹身。他让德米特里厄斯看起来很小。“你好吗？”“全A。”“我需要什么来满足我的要求？”他们一起俯身在电脑前看着他的日程表。
Oh, no. That doesn't work.
哦，不。那不行。
That doesn't work? 12:30?
那不行？12:30？
Then something happens I totally didn't expect. In the middle of registering Demetrius for his college courses, we call his dad.
然后发生了一件我完全没预料到的事。在给德米特里厄斯注册大学课程的过程中，我们给他的爸爸打了电话。
Hello, sir?
你好，先生？
Yep.
是的。
How are you? My name is Ray Cartagena. I'm Demetrius's success coach here. And we're trying to build his schedule for him now. We wanted to reach out to you and get your approval on it. So--
你好吗？我叫雷·卡塔赫纳。我是德米特里厄斯这里的成功教练。我们正在尝试现在为他建立日程表。我们想联系你并获得你对它的批准。所以……
Some of the classes--
有些课程……
Demetrius's dad seems to take an usual amount of interest in the minutiae of his son's schedule. No three classes on one day, one class on another day because then you have too much time on your hands.
德米特里厄斯的爸爸似乎对儿子日程表的细节有着不寻常的兴趣。“不要一天三门课，另一天一门课，因为那样你手里有太多的时间了。”
I mean, I have a history with him. And too much time--
我是说，我和他有一段历史。而且太多时间……
I have a history with him. And too much time on your hands, he says, can lead to issues.
我和他有一段历史。而且你手里有太多时间，他说，可能导致问题。
--on your hands could lead to issues. So I'm like--
……在手里可能导致问题。所以我说……
This is weird. Demetrius is acing his classes. His professors really like him. He spends a lot of time in the computer lab. And he wants to join student government. Why is his dad all over him? He's in college. If they can't find a better schedule for him, his dad promises, this semester around, I will find a way to occupy his time.
这很怪。德米特里厄斯在课上表现出色。教授们真的很喜欢他。他在计算机实验室待了很多时间。他想加入学生会。为什么他爸爸对他管得这么严？他上大学了。如果他们找不到更好的日程表，他爸爸承诺，这个学期，我会找到一个占用他时间的方法。
This semester around, I will figure out a way to occupy his time.
这个学期，我会想出一个占用他时间的方法。
Demetrius seems a little embarrassed when we walk out. His bravado has kind of drained away. So I ask about his dad. What's the deal? We sit on a park bench. Demetrius stares straight ahead.
当我们走出来时，德米特里厄斯似乎有点尴尬。他的那种狂妄已经消失了。所以我问起他爸爸。怎么回事？我们坐在公园的长椅上。德米特里厄斯直视前方。
He doesn't trust me. So my dad is just stuck in oh, but he messed up once. He messed up once. It was one time in the history, once that he messed up. Therefore, he will mess up every other time he attempts something for the rest of his life because once he messed up. Once. Once.
他不信任我。所以我爸爸只是卡在“哦，但他曾经搞砸过。他曾经搞砸过。”在历史上只有一次，一次他搞砸了。因此，他余生中尝试任何事情都会搞砸，因为有一次他搞砸了。一次。一次。
And it was big. It was very big. It was very bad, spectacularly messed up. It was just really bad, what I did. And then it's good. It's spectacularly good what I'm doing now. It's really good, what I'm doing.
而且那次很大。它非常大。它非常糟糕，搞砸得相当壮观。我做的那件事真的很糟糕。然后现在好。我正在做的这件事相当壮观地好。我正在做的这件事真的很好。
The story about the once is about to spill out. And this story, it tells you a lot about why the graduation rate at community colleges is one in three, how even someone as confident as Demetrius could become a dropout instead of the one who makes it.
关于那“一次”的故事正要流露出来。而这个故事，它告诉你很多关于为什么社区大学的毕业率是三比一，即使像德米特里厄斯这样自信的人怎么可能会变成一个辍学生而不是那个成功的人。
The once is theatrical. It's an elaborate mistake. And it's not a story about this year. It's a story about last year. Because when I met Demetrius, I did not know this is actually his second freshman year, his second time around as a freshman in college.
那“一次”是戏剧性的。它是一个精心设计的错误。而且这不是关于今年的故事。这是关于去年的故事。因为当我遇见德米特里厄斯时，我不知道这实际上是他的第二个大一，他第二次作为大一新生上大学。
The first time he went to college, it wasn't the South Bronx. In fact, it couldn't feel more different at Finger Lakes Community College. Woods, wineries, lakes, five hours north of New York City. His mom dropped him off.
他第一次去大学，那不是南布朗克斯。事实上，它在手指湖社区大学感觉再不同不过了。树林、酒厂、湖泊，纽约市以北五小时。他妈妈送他过去。
And when she dropped me off and went back to New York, I was sitting in my room. I was like, I'm alone. This is it. I'm here on my own now. It was somber, but at the same time it was exciting. Like, I'm alone. And then it was like, I'm alone!
当我妈把我放下并回到纽约时，我坐在房间里。我就想，“我孤身一人。就是这样。我现在独自在这里。”那很沉重，但同时也很令人兴奋。就像，“我孤身一人。”然后就像，“我孤身一人！”
My roommate hadn't gotten there yet. I was like, this is pretty awesome. I stepped outside as if to test it. Like, open the door, looked around. And I was like, I can just go, just go anywhere. Like, this is good. Then school started. And I was like, OK. School's the main focus. I'm going to make sure I do it.
我的室友还没到。我就想，“这太棒了。”我走到外面就像要测试一下它。就像，打开门，四处看了看。我就想，“我可以去，随便去哪里。这很好。”然后学校开始了。我就想，“好的。学校是重点。我要确保我完成它。”
And at first, I was. But then, I started going to parties when I should be studying or doing homework, started hanging out late. Xbox One and PS4 came out during that stretch.
起初，我是。但后来，我开始在我应该学习或做作业的时候去参加派对，开始很晚出去玩。Xbox One和PS4就是在那个阶段出来的。
Demetrius also noticed it's way easier to get girlfriends in college than in high school. But the big difference between college and high school-- nobody is there to make you go to class. Nobody is collecting your homework. Nobody's making sure you're keeping up with the reading.
德米特里厄斯还注意到大学比高中更容易交到女朋友。但大学和高中之间最大的区别——没人会在那里强迫你去上课。没人会收集你的作业。没人确保你跟得上阅读。
On occasion, I would just cut class and not go.
偶尔，我就会逃课不去了。
He says nobody seemed to notice. He got letters from the school. He ignored them. His grades were dropping. And then late into the semester, a relative died that he was close to, and he had to go back to the city for the funeral. He came back to campus but never went back to class. He felt terrible, totally depressed.
他说没人注意到。他收到了学校的信。他无视了它们。他的成绩在下降。然后在学期晚些时候，一位亲戚去世了，他很亲近的人，他不得不回城参加葬礼。他回到了校园，但再没回去上课。他感觉糟糕透了，彻底抑郁。
There would be times where I would just be in my room. I would just sit in there and cry. And at the same time, it made me feel worse because I knew I was failing. I knew I screwed up in my first semester.
会有那么些时候，我只会待在房间里。我只会坐在那里哭。而同时，这让我感觉更糟，因为我知道我失败了。我知道我在第一学期搞砸了。
Demetrius let everything slide. The checks he was getting from the government to cover his housing, he spent those. He only paid the rent once. He says he was confused about when he was supposed to pay what. By the end of the semester, there was nothing left. He owed a couple thousand dollars.
德米特里厄斯让一切下滑。他从政府那里收到的用来支付房租的支票，他把它们花了。他只付了一次房租。他说他很困惑应该什么时候付什么。到学期末，什么都不剩了。他欠了几千美元。
He saw his family for Christmas break. He could've confessed everything. He could have gotten help. But he didn't do any of that.
他在寒假见到了家人。他本可以承认一切。他本可以寻求帮助。但他什么都没做。
Obviously, I lied and said I did well in school and never brought up the debt.
显然，我撒谎说我在学校表现很好，从未提及债务。
And after Christmas vacation, that's when he got into some real magical thinking. He kicked up his deception to a whole new level. He was like, the circumstances of my life are on a need to know basis, and nobody needs to know. He thought he could turn things around all by himself and secretly handled this entire episode.
而且在圣诞假期之后，那是他陷入一些真正魔法思维的时候。他把他的欺骗提升到了一个全新的水平。他就像，“我生活的环境是在有必要时才披露的，没人有必要知道。”他认为他能完全独自扭转局面并秘密处理整个事件。
Here was his plan-- get a full-time job at the Taco Bell, earn enough money to pay back the money he owed for his housing, never tell anyone what happened, and quietly re-enroll next semester.
这是他的计划——在塔可钟（Taco Bell）找一份全职工作，赚足够的钱来支付他欠的房租，永远不要告诉任何人发生了什么，然后悄悄下学期重新注册。
Honestly, I never even registered for classes. I basically started living on the run. I was hiding out in my best friend's room immediately next door. I felt like this is my mistake. It was my problem. I messed up, so I need to handle it on my own.
说实话，我甚至从未注册课程。我基本上开始过着逃亡的生活。我躲在我隔壁最好的朋友房间里。我感觉这是我的错误。这是我的问题。我搞砸了，所以我需要自己处理它。
So thousands of dollars in debt, college dropout, 300 miles away from his family-- this was Demetrius's life. He copied a friend's transcript into Microsoft Word, changed the name to his, and texted it to his dad like, see how great I'm doing in school?
所以欠债几千美元，大学辍学生，离家人300英里远——这就是德米特里厄斯的生活。他把朋友的成绩单复制到微软Word里，把名字改成他的，并把它发短信给他爸爸，“看看我在学校做得多好？”
Three months passed like this. And it might have continued for longer. Except then, that April, deep into Demetrius's would-be second semester, his dad decided to surprise him at school.
三个月就这么过去了。而它可能还会持续更久。除非，那是四月，深入德米特里厄斯本应是第二个学期的时候，他爸爸决定在学校给他个惊喜。
So I'm talking to him. And he's saying to me, well, Dad, the weekend would be better because I'm not as busy with school work and work. So the weekend would be great. We could do anything. I said, sure. No problem. I'm on my way. He has no idea I'm on my way.
所以我正在和他交谈。他对我说，“好吧，爸爸，周末会更好，因为我没那么忙于学校作业和工作。”所以周末会很棒。我们可以做任何事。我说，“当然。没问题。我在路上了。”他不知道我在路上。
Please meet the man from the speakerphone, the father of Demetrius Wilson, Demetrius Wilson, Sr. He is a big guy, a sanitation worker for New York City. He is incredibly friendly, loves to talk. So back in April, Demetrius the dad shows up at the school with his younger son, Elijah. It was Elijah's spring break. Their plan was to have a little vacation, drive around the wineries after saying hi to Demetrius, Jr.
请见见免提电话里那个人，德米特里厄斯·威尔逊的父亲，德米特里厄斯·威尔逊高级。他是个大块头，纽约市的环卫工人。他非常友好，喜欢交谈。所以回到四月，德米特里厄斯的爸爸带着他年幼的儿子以利亚出现在学校。那是以利亚的春假。他们的计划是度个小假，在向小德米特里厄斯打招呼后在酒厂开车转转。
He said, I'm in room 220 or 222 or something. So I see these two girls in front of his door that he said he was in. Oh, he's living the life. This is a good dude. I'm so proud of him. These two pretty girls are standing there. And I was like, are they gonna-- you're looking for Demetrius?
他说，“我在220号或222号房间或者什么地方。”所以我看到他说的门前有两个女孩。哦，他过着这种生活。这是个好小伙。我为他感到自豪。这两个漂亮的女孩站在那儿。我心想，她们会……你在找德米特里厄斯吗？
I thought they were going to say that. They didn't say that. I go up to the room. The girls take off. They had nothing to do with him. I go to the room, open the door. So they're just sitting there. Hi, hi. I see the video game on the big screen.
我以为她们会这么说。她们没那么说。我走到房间。女孩们走了。她们和他无关。我走到房间，打开门。他们就坐在那儿。嗨，嗨。我看到大屏幕上的视频游戏。
Demetrius stuck to the policy-- admit nothing.
德米特里厄斯坚持政策——什么都别承认。
I mean, I was still acting like everything's great. Like, oh, hey, Dad. Hey, great to see you.
我是说，我还是表现得好像一切都很好。就像，“哦，嘿，爸爸。嘿，见到你真高兴。”
And he says, oh, I would be in class except it was canceled. His dad looks at him.
他说，“哦，我会在上课，除非它被取消了。”他爸爸看着他。
So no class today? Teacher wasn't sick yesterday? You just found out on short notice? All right. I'm gonna let that ride.
所以今天没课？老师昨天没生病？你刚刚在短时间内发现的？好吧。我要让它过去。
What are you thinking, though? Are you thinking anything?
不过你在想什么？你在想什么吗？
Oh, yeah. Right then, we got a thing called jokes. When someone's running jokes, you can see it.
哦，是的。就在那时，我们有一种叫“笑话”的东西。当某人在开这种笑话时，你能看得出来。
Running jokes, it's slang-- like running a con game.
“开笑话”，这是俚语——就像在开一场骗局。
Hey, people do it all the time. Like, they say something to you, and you're like, that don't match up with what they just said. So you just keep it in your pocket until another thing come up.
嘿，人们总是这么做。比如，他们告诉你某事，你就会想，“那和他们刚说的对不上。”所以你就把它放在兜里，直到另一件事发生。
So now, they're watching each other, saying nothing, waiting it out. Next day, Demetrius's dad makes a move. Hey, I want to go to one of your classes. Let's go to one of your classes together.
所以现在，他们在观察对方，什么也不说，等着它过去。第二天，德米特里厄斯的爸爸采取了行动。“嘿，我想去上你的一门课。让我们一起去上你的一门课吧。”
We walk around, all the way around. Finally, we get to another part of the campus. He goes into an empty trailer. I'm on it now.
我们四处走，一直转。终于，我们到了校园的另一部分。他走进一个空拖车。我抓住了。
Yeah.
是的。
Now we're in an empty-- no one's in the class. Class is cut off, lights off. Now, I'm in there like this, sitting there. Elijah still don't know, says, where's everybody? So he says, just one minute, and walks out the door.
现在我们在一个空的……没人在班里。课停了，灯关着。现在，我坐在那儿这样，坐在那儿。以利亚还不知道，说，“大家都在哪儿？”所以他说，“只是一分钟”，然后走出门口。
All right, homeboy, take me to the office. Huh? Huh? Take me to the office. Oh, it's closed. Well, then it should be a short trip. Take me to the office. If it's closed, it'll be a short trip. Right?
好了，兄弟，带我去办公室。哈？哈？带我去办公室。哦，它关着。那么那应该是个短途。带我去办公室。如果它关着，那应该是个短途。对吧？
I can't stand it. Like, I'm so nervous.
我受不了了。就像，我太紧张了。
So now I'm like this. We get in there. Hi, how you doing? My name is Demetrius Wilson. Where is he supposed to be? His name is Demetrius Wilson.
所以我现在这样。我们进去。你好，你怎么样？我叫德米特里厄斯·威尔逊。他应该在哪里？他的名字是德米特里厄斯·威尔逊。
The receptionist looks up Demetrius's name on the computer and goes quiet.
接待员在电脑上查找德米特里厄斯的名字，然后安静下来。
She looks at me. She looks at him. Looks at me, looks at him, looks at the board. Don't know what to say. Sir, he's not registered this year.
她看着我。她看着他。看着我，看着他，看着屏幕。不知道说什么好。“先生，他今年没注册。”
Demetrius marches his son out to the car, shuts him inside, and takes a walk. And his thoughts are going 100 miles an hour. He kind of wants to knock his son out and drive away. But of course, that's not what he's going to do.
德米特里厄斯把儿子带到车前，把他锁在里面，然后走开了。他的思绪转得飞快。他有点想把儿子击昏然后开车离开。但当然，那不是他要做的事。
I just walk. I walk, and I walk. And I'm like, oh, man. You failed him. You should have been there, man. No, you can't hurt him now. What do you do, man? Do you hurt him? No, don't hurt him. If you hurt him, man, then what do you prove, man?
我只是走。我走啊走。我就想，“哦，天哪。你让他失败了。你应该在那里，伙计。不，你现在不能伤害他。你做什么，伙计？你伤害他吗？不，别伤害他。伙计，如果你伤害他，那么你证明了什么，伙计？”
He can't be up here. Can he go back to school? This is me walking around the campus.
他不能待在这里。他能回去上学吗？这就是我走在校园里时想的事情。
This is what he was thinking about-- first of all, Demetrius's dad wasn't around for lots of little Demetrius's childhood. The parents broke up, and he'd see little Demetrius maybe every few weeks or so, sometimes less.
这就是他想的事情——首先，德米特里厄斯的爸爸在小德米特里厄斯的童年里并没有待过很久。父母分开了，他可能每隔几周见到小德米特里厄斯，有时更少。
So when his son slacked off in high school, he blamed himself partly for not being there. Now his son's slacking off in college. What do you expect? Also, Demetrius's dad has a college degree. But his first time around, he dropped out, when he tried state college in Norfolk, Virginia. He says he had this problem when he was young where he would come right up to the edge of being successful and then pull back. He knows how his kid must be feeling right now, how hard it can be to push yourself through your doubts.
所以当他的儿子在高中偷懒时，他部分责怪自己没有在那儿。现在他的儿子在大学里偷懒。你指望什么呢？另外，德米特里厄斯的爸爸有大学学位。但当他第一次尝试的时候，他辍学了，当他在弗吉尼亚州诺福克的州立大学尝试时。他说他年轻时有这个问题，就是他会直接来到成功边缘然后退缩。他知道他的孩子现在肯定感觉如何，推动自己度过怀疑有多难。
I mean, for me, it definitely was like I could have done a lot more if I was pushed. I think what happens with a lot of people is that whatever makes them go over that edge, it's more than just a talent and intelligence. It's something else.
我是说，对我来说，这绝对就像如果我被推动的话，我本可以做更多。我想很多人发生的情况是，无论什么让他们越过那个边缘，那不仅仅是才华和智力。那是别的东西。
It could very well be to follow somebody, follow a family member. They did it. I'm going to do it. The thing that's stopping them could be, there's no one else that's done this. Who am I to think that I could do it?
那很可能是跟随某人，跟随一个家庭成员。他们做到了。我也要做。阻止他们的那件事可能是，没有其他人做过这个。我是谁，竟然认为我能做到？
So Demetrius, Sr., comes up with a plan for his son Demetrius. Nothing's going to happen in his life that I don't know about. I need to know everything. He decides to bring little Demetrius back to New York City, enroll him in college in the Bronx, 10 minutes away from his dad's apartment.
所以，德米特里厄斯高级为他的儿子德米特里厄斯想出一个计划。他生命中不会发生任何我不知道的事情。我需要知道一切。他决定把小德米特里厄斯带回纽约市，让他进入布朗克斯的大学，离他爸爸的公寓10分钟远。
Again, Demetrius's dad works for New York Sanitation. And his garage is directly across the street from where Demetrius goes to school.
再说一次，德米特里厄斯的爸爸在纽约环卫局工作。他的车库就在德米特里厄斯上学的马路对面。
I'm on it in his school. I'm on it at his job. I'm on it at home. There's no you make the decision. No. I make the decision, or we discuss it. But you don't make the decision and come back to me because who are you to make the decision? You haven't even had that much experience.
我在他的学校盯着他。我在他的工作地点盯着他。我在家盯着他。没有“你做决定”这回事。不。我做决定，或者我们讨论它。但你不能做决定然后再回到我这儿，因为你算什么人做决定？你甚至没有多少经验。
Demetrius is on his dad's couch every night, at school across the street from him every day, on weekends at a job that his dad approves of-- working as a cashier at the FAO Schwarz in midtown. They check in every day, a few times a day.
德米特里厄斯每天晚上都在他爸爸的沙发上，每天在马路对面他上学的学校，周末在爸爸批准的工作地点——在曼哈顿中城的FAO Schwarz做收银员。他们每天联系几次。
The difference between Demetrius and myself, quite honestly, is that I didn't have me. The moment you say, you can't do it. Oh, I don't have to do it. There should be something to push you. And sometimes it has to be external. I don't think I had it externally.
老实说，德米特里厄斯和我之间的区别是，我没有“我”。当你说的时刻，“你做不到。”“哦，我不必做它。”应该有东西推动你。有时它必须是外在的。我认为我没有外在的动力。
And I think internally, I knew I could. But if someone-- nah, don't turn this way. There ain't no back. You got to go. If he for some reason or another wants to stop, he's going to have to work really hard at it. And he can't do it in my house.
我认为内在的，我知道我能做到。但如果某人……“不，别转这儿。没后路。你必须走。”如果由于某种原因他想停下来，他将不得不非常努力地工作。而且他不能在我家里做。
There's a popular idea right now among people studying why kids drop out of college. There's this whole set of skills that students lack-- non-academic skills like organizing their time, knowing who to ask for what. And that lacking those skills is one of the biggest reasons kids fail. And that's something schools are trying to address so they can keep their students.
现在在研究孩子们为什么辍学的人中间有一个流行的观点。学生们缺少整套技能——非学术技能，比如安排他们的时间，知道向谁询问什么。而且缺乏那些技能是孩子们失败的最大原因之一。而那是学校正在尝试解决的事情，这样他们就能留住他们的学生。
The way that lots of schools see it is that they have to develop their own Demetrius's dad. They call it an intrusive adviser or an enhanced adviser. Demetrius's new school, Hostos, they're trying this thing. That's what their success coach program is. When Navy Reserve guy Ray calls Demetrius's dad on the phone to figure out his one class on one day issue, that's intrusive advising, which in this case doesn't look so different from parenting.
许多学校看待它的方式是，他们必须发展他们自己的“德米特里厄斯爸爸”。他们称之为“侵入性顾问”或“增强型顾问”。德米特里厄斯的新学校，霍斯托斯，他们正在尝试这个。那正是他们的成功教练计划。当海军预备役雷在电话里联系德米特里厄斯的爸爸搞清楚他一天一门课的问题时，那就是侵入性建议，在这种情况下，这看起来和做父母没什么两样。
Of course, parenting can be a thankless job and seems to be when it comes to Demetrius. He doesn't credit his turnaround from dropout to straight A student to his dad holding him accountable. Demetrius mostly gives the credit to himself, to a change in his own frame of mind.
当然，做父母可能是一项吃力不讨好的工作，对于德米特里厄斯来说确实如此。他没有把从辍学生到全A学生的转变归功于他爸爸让他负责。德米特里厄斯主要把功劳归于他自己，归于他自己心态的转变。
I learned from my mistakes. I got rid of my mental whatevers that caused me to make them in the first place.
我从我的错误中学习。我清除了导致我犯错误的心理杂念。
His dad doesn't care that Demetrius thinks he did it on its own. In fact, he's happy about that. He prefers that. He wants him to feel empowered and not overthink it. He wants his son to move on and not spend time reflecting on why he got stuck a year ago. That could stagnate his son, whose only focus is supposed to be doing well in school.
他爸爸不在乎德米特里厄斯认为是他自己做的。事实上，他为那感到高兴。他更喜欢那样。他想要他感到受权而不要过度思考。他想要他的儿子前进，不要花时间反思他为什么一年前会被卡住。那可能会让他儿子停滞不前，他唯一的焦点本应是在学校表现好。
I want him to just keep flying, he told me the other day, not so close to the sun that he melts his wings but just keep moving forward. Don't pull back. Stay in motion.
我想要他继续飞行，他前几天告诉我，不要太靠近太阳以至于融化了他的翅膀，但只要继续前进。不要退缩。保持动态。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show.
佐伊·查斯是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Three, The Favorite. So we close our show today with this example of information provided on a need-to-know basis from one of our producers, Stephanie Foo.
第三幕，宠儿。所以我们今天用这个在有必要时才披露信息的例子结束我们的节目，来自我们的制片人之一，斯蒂芬妮·傅。
When I was in the seventh grade, I got an assignment to write a one-page essay about my favorite place in the world. I wrote 10 pages, single spaced, about Malaysia.
当我在七年级时，我收到一个作业，写一篇关于我世界上最喜欢的地方的一页文章。我写了10页，单倍行距，关于马来西亚。
I moved to America from Malaysia when I was three years old, but the rest of my family still lives there. We went back a lot when I was little. And so I remember crawling under ferns and hibiscus in the yard, catching moths the size of my head, playing hide and seek during monsoon storms.
我三岁时从马来西亚搬到美国，但我其余的家人仍然住在那里。我小时候经常回去。所以我记得爬在院子里的蕨类植物和木槿花下，捕捉和我头一样大的飞蛾，在季风暴雨中玩捉迷藏。
But in that essay, I didn't write about the main reason why I loved Malaysia. I loved Malaysia most because Malaysia loved me. I was the favorite child, and not even the extra serving of cake kind of favorite-- the kind of favorite where everyone would straight up say at family gatherings, oh, Stephanie's the best. My aunts would tell their children, why can't you be more like her? Then they'd buy me all the toys I wanted. And the person leading this campaign was the matriarch of our family, my dad's aunt. We all called her Auntie.
但在那篇文章里，我没写我爱马来西亚的主要原因。我最爱马来西亚是因为马来西亚爱我。我是最受宠的孩子，甚至不是那种多给一份蛋糕的受宠——那种家里人在家庭聚会上会直截了当地说，“哦，斯蒂芬妮是最棒的。”的受宠。我的阿姨们会告诉她们的孩子，“为什么你们不能像她一样？”然后她们会给我买所有我想要的玩具。而领导这场运动的是我们家庭的族长，我爸爸的阿姨。我们都叫她“阿姨”。
Every time I walked into a room, Auntie would reach for me and coo, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]. She's so well behaved. She's so nice. She saved me all the best pieces of the chicken, taught me mahjong, asked only me to sit on her lap on the big papasan as she taught me songs in Chinese.
每次我走进房间，阿姨就会伸向我，咕哝着，“她很乖。她很好。”她把所有最好吃的鸡肉留给我，教我打麻将，只要求我坐在她的大藤椅上，教我中文歌。
The other adults fell in line to say something nice about my eyes, my dimples. I remember I had this cousin who wanted to be an artist when she grew up. She filled up an entire bookshelf with her sketches. I showed up and started doodling, and everyone flocked around me, telling me I had natural talent. My cousin stormed off and didn't talk to me for days.
其他成年人随之说些关于我的眼睛、酒窝的好听的话。我记得我有个堂姐，长大想成为一名艺术家。她用她的素描填满了一个书架。我出现并开始乱涂乱画，每个人都围着我，告诉我我有天赋。我的堂姐冲了出去，好几天没跟我说话。
I was proud to be Auntie's favorite because even though she was under five feet tall with Coke-bottle glasses, she was also a total badass. Auntie grew up destitute with three sisters and a single mother in Japanese-occupied Malaysia. The girls shaved their heads to avoid being harassed by the Japanese soldiers, and they opened a gambling den where they hustled patrons out of money and sold opium.
我为成为阿姨的宠儿感到自豪，因为尽管她身高不到五英尺，戴着可乐瓶底厚的眼镜，但她也是个十足的硬汉。阿姨在贫困中长大，有三个姐妹和一位单身母亲在被日本占领的马来西亚。女孩们剃光头以避免被日本士兵骚扰，她们开了一家赌窝，从客人们那里骗钱并卖鸦片。
She had an impassioned opinion about everything. When she hated something, she screwed up her face in disgust and would actually bang her fist on the table, declaring [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]. Don't like Nicki Minaj. Why she got blonde, white people hair when she's a black woman?
她对每件事都有激情的观点。当她讨厌某件事时，她会厌恶地扭曲她的脸，实际上会用拳头敲桌子，宣布，“不喜欢妮琪·米娜。她是个黑人女性，为什么她要留金发、白人的头发？”
Not that Auntie had ever met a black woman. She didn't like traveling. She didn't like cheese. Her decisiveness sometimes didn't quite make sense. Like one time when I offered her an apple, she shook her head and said, apple taste just like potato. And I'd rather have potato.
不是说阿姨见过黑人女性。她不喜欢旅行。她不喜欢奶酪。她的果断有时并不太说得通。比如有一次我递给她一个苹果，她摇了摇头说，“苹果尝起来就像土豆。我宁愿要土豆。”
The things she loved seemed just as impassioned and just as arbitrary-- the lottery, which she won over 40 times in her life, this one ditzy girl on the Korean soap operas, and me. I once asked my mom why I got the special treatment I did. She said it was simple. I was the favorite because my dad was the eldest son in the family and I was his firstborn child. This sounded enough like something out of an Amy Tan novel for me to believe it. I left it at that.
她爱的东西看起来同样有激情，同样任性——彩票，她一生赢了40多次；韩国肥皂剧里那个没头脑的女孩；还有我。我有一次问我妈妈为什么我得到了那种特殊的待遇。她说这很简单。我是最受宠的，因为我爸爸是家里的大儿子，而我是他的第一个孩子。这听起来像谭恩美小说里出来的东西，足够让我相信了。我就让它那样了。
But things all started to change when I was 13. Everyone in the family heard about that one day in August when my mom told my dad and me that she was leaving us. They heard about the lawyers, the money, the house. And they heard about what a brat I was after, which I was.
但当我是13岁时，事情开始改变了。家里每个人都听说了八月的那一天，我妈妈告诉我爸爸和我，她要离开我们。他们听说了律师、钱、房子。而且他们听说了在那之后我是一个多么顽劣的孩子，我确实是。
I argued with my teachers, flunked out of a lot of classes. When my dad started dating, he wasn't around much, didn't even come home lots of nights. And I started fighting with him all the time. I set his copy of Parenting Your Out-of-Control Teenager on fire and almost burned the apartment down in the process.
我和我的老师争吵，挂了很多课。当我的爸爸开始约会时，他不太常在家，甚至很多晚上都没回家。我开始和他整天争吵。我烧了他那本《管教你失控的青少年》的书，差点在过程中把公寓烧了。
Two years after my mother left, my dad moved out completely, went to his girlfriend's place. I found a roast chicken on the kitchen counter once a week. But basically, he left me in the house on my own. I was 16 and furious.
在我母亲离开两年后，我爸爸完全搬走了，去了他女朋友那里。我偶尔在厨房柜台上找到一只烤鸡。但基本上，他把我自己留在那房子里。我当时16岁，愤怒极了。
I knew my family in Malaysia got an earful about my bad behavior. I got a couple of emails from aunts telling me I needed to get it together. And that cousin who loved to draw, she wrote me to say I ought to feel bad for breaking up my parents' marriage. So I stopped emailing my family.
我知道我在马来西亚的家人因为我糟糕的表现感到不快。我收到几封阿姨发来的电子邮件，告诉我我需要振作起来。还有那个喜欢画画的堂姐，她写信给我说我应该因为毁了我父母的婚姻而感到糟糕。所以我停止给我家人发电子邮件。
I got up the nerve to visit Malaysia again after I graduated from high school-- not with my dad, though. I brought my boyfriend instead. And things started off normal enough. Auntie cracked jokes about my boyfriend's surprising ability to eat spicy food. She'd call him "the white devil" and cackle.
我高中毕业后有了勇气再次访问马来西亚——不过不是和我爸爸一起。我带了我的男朋友一起。事情开始时还算正常。阿姨开玩笑说我男朋友出人意料地能吃辣。她会叫他“白魔鬼”并咯咯笑。
But everyone seemed a little reserved. I wasn't the golden child anymore. I had a filthy mouth and blue hair. I picked fights about their opinions and their politics. Finally, someone asked me how my dad was. I said I didn't know. I said he was an asshole.
但每个人看起来都有点矜持。我不再是金童了。我说话很粗鲁，头发是蓝色的。我因为他们的观点和政治问题挑起争端。最后，有人问我我爸爸怎么样。我说我不知道。我说他是个混蛋。
They got defensive. Auntie and the rest of my family asked me why I couldn't be a better daughter. They asked me if the stories they'd heard were true-- the one about the burning books, the one about me chucking my dad's car keys into some bushes.
他们变得防卫起来。阿姨和我的其他家人问我为什么不能做一个更好的女儿。他们问我听到的故事是不是真的——那个关于烧书的故事，那个关于我把爸爸的车钥匙扔进灌木丛的故事。
OK, yes. It was true. I had done all of those things. But then I realized they didn't know that my dad had moved out. They didn't know that most days, it was all I could do to microwave a Hot Pocket for dinner. When I told them, they didn't believe it.
好吧，是的。是真的。我做了所有那些事。但后来我意识到他们不知道我爸爸已经搬走了。他们不知道大多数日子里，我能做的一切就是为晚餐加热一个热狗袋。当我告诉他们时，他们不相信。
Before they took me to the airport, Auntie grabbed hold of me and hugged me tight to her. And then she whispered in my ear, you are not a good person, OK? You need to become a better person. Then she let go and walked away.
在他们带我去机场前，阿姨紧紧地抓住了我，紧紧地抱住我。然后她在我的耳边低语，“你不是一个好人，好吗？你需要成为一个更好的人。”然后她放手走开了。
I didn't go back to Malaysia after that. Instead, I grew up. I learned how to land a job, make a paella, buy a car. I learned a few deep breathing exercises. I didn't set anything else on fire.
在那之后我没再回马来西亚。相反，我长大了。我学会了找一份工作，做一份海鲜饭，买一辆车。我学了一些深呼吸的练习。我没再烧任何东西。
Finally, a couple years ago, my father called me and told me that Auntie was sick. She was stable, but I should make a point to visit. So I went back with my dad. It felt weird traveling with him because for years, we'd never spent more than a couple hours together.
终于，几年前，我父亲打电话给我，告诉我阿姨病了。她状况稳定，但我应该专程去拜访。所以我带我爸爸回去。和他一起旅行感觉很怪，因为多年来，我们从没在一起待过超过几个小时。
But when Auntie saw me, she was so excited she almost fell over. She grabbed the edge of the table next to her just in time and cried out, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] You're so pretty. I relaxed.
但当阿姨见到我时，她太兴奋了，差点摔倒。她及时抓住桌边，喊道，“你真漂亮。”我放松了。
All was forgiven. Auntie loved me again. She brought me food. She held my hand as we watched TV. I stayed with her a little over a week. I started recording some of my conversations with her. I wanted to remember this.
一切都被原谅了。阿姨又爱我了。她给我带食物。我们看电视时她握着我的手。我待了一周多一点。我开始录制我与她的一些对话。我想记住这个。
Auntie told me stories from the gambling den, told me about my grandma flirting with boys for free sodas. And then she started talking about when I was a little kid. And she said this thing that, when she said it, felt like she took a box full of everything I thought I knew about my relationship with her, about my relationship with Malaysia, and dumped it out on the floor.
阿姨给我讲了关于赌窝的故事，讲了我奶奶为了免费汽水调情男孩的故事。然后她开始谈论我小时候。然后她说了一件事，当她说出它时，感觉就像她拿了一个装满我自以为知道关于我和她关系、关于我和马来西亚关系的一切的盒子，把它倒在了地板上。
I'll play you some of this. Take note-- Auntie's English wasn't very good. She could only talk in the present tense, even when she was referring to the past. And she didn't have her dentures in at this point. But she started banging her fist on the table, and she said that the reason everyone had been kind to me when I was a kid was because they all knew that I'd suffered a lot. Here's the tape.
我会给你们放一些这个。注意——阿姨的英语不太好。她只能用现在时谈话，即使她提到过去时。在这个时候她没戴假牙。但她开始用拳头敲桌子，她说每个人小时候对我很好，是因为他们都知道我吃了很多苦。这是录音。
Everybody is kind to you because everyone knows that you suffer a lot. That's why they're so kind to you.
每个人对你很好，因为每个人都知道你吃了很多苦。这就是为什么他们对你那么好。
Wow.
哇。
Because they realize that when you're young, you suffer a lot. Yeah.
因为他们意识到当你年轻时，你吃了很多苦。是的。
And when she said that, something clicked. I knew what she was talking about. She was talking about my mom. When I was a kid, if I lost something or said something wrong or didn't clean a dish properly, my mother would scream, hit me. Sometimes she'd threaten to kill herself. I was never not scared growing up.
当她说出那句话时，我脑子里闪过一些东西。我知道她在说什么。她在说我的妈妈。当我小时候，如果我丢了东西或者说错了话，或者没把碗洗干净，我妈妈会尖叫，打我。有时她会威胁要自杀。我成长过程中从没感到不害怕。
That's how I remember it, anyway. My mother remembers it differently. Before I go on, this is from the email she sent to our fact checker.
无论如何，我就是这样记得的。我妈妈记得的不一样。在我继续之前，这是她发给我们事实核查员的电子邮件。
Quote, "My daughter's stories about me that she has related to you are figments of her imagination or, at best, highly prejudiced memories. If released publicly, I would consider these fabrications and distortions about me as personally very damaging." End quote.
引用，“我女儿关于我的故事，她向你叙述的那些，都是她想象的产物，或者充其量是带有高度偏见的记忆。如果公开发布，我会认为这些关于我的虚构和歪曲是极其损害个人声誉的。”引用结束。
But what my Auntie told me on tape was that basically, everyone was so nice to me not because I was the oldest child of the first-born son and not because my cheeks were chubby but because they saw what my mother was doing to me.
但我阿姨在录音里告诉我的基本上是，每个人对我那么好不是因为我是长子的第一个孩子，也不是因为我的脸颊胖乎乎的，而是因为他们看到了我妈妈在对我做什么。
Did you see her beat me?
你看到她打我了吗？
Yeah. Everybody also seen her.
是的。每个人也都看到了。
I'm asking Auntie if she saw my mom beat me. And she says everyone saw.
我在问阿姨她是否看到我妈妈打我。她说每个人都看到了。
You know that scene in Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind where he's in Barnes & Noble and slowly, all off the lights turn off, one by one, leaving him in darkness? As Auntie was talking into my tape recorder, it felt like the opposite, like all the lights were turning on.
你知道《美丽心灵的永恒阳光》里金·凯瑞在书店的那一幕，灯光一盏一盏地熄灭，让他陷入黑暗吗？当阿姨对着我的录音机说话时，感觉恰恰相反，就像所有的灯光都亮了起来。
I saw my family, saw Auntie popping back up in those memories in a way I'd never imagined before-- with them listening through walls, peering around corners. Suddenly, I remembered this one time in my uncle's house in Malaysia. I wasn't allowed to eat dinner. Instead, my mom told me I had to cross my arms, pull on my earlobes, and do squats in front of my family, who ate their meal in silence.
我看到了我的家人，看到了阿姨以一种我从未想象过的方式出现在那些记忆中——他们在墙那边听着，在角落里窥视。突然，我想起了在马来西亚舅舅家有一次。我不被允许吃晚饭。相反，我妈妈告诉我必须交叉双臂，拉住耳垂，在我的家人面前做深蹲，他们沉默地吃着他们的饭。
And then there was a time during a visit when I was six, and I disagreed with my mom about what my homework assignment was. She started beating me with a ruler. I think it was a ruler. It went on for a long time.
还有一次访问期间，我六岁时，我和我妈妈对我的家庭作业是什么有分歧。她开始用尺子打我。我想那是一把尺子。这持续了很长时间。
At some point, I tried to hide under a table. As she pulled me out by the legs, I started to scream for mercy. I knew that the house was full of family. I wondered why nobody was coming to help me. I thought, they must not be able to hear me. I felt totally alone.
在某个时候，我试图躲在桌子底下。当她拽着我的腿把我拉出来时，我开始尖叫乞求怜悯。我知道房子里住满了家人。我奇怪为什么没有人来帮我。我想，“他们一定听不到我。”我感到完全孤单。
I was not alone. Here's me and Auntie again. I'm speaking in Manglish, Malaysian pidgin English. I never thought this would be on the radio.
我不是孤单的。这是我和阿姨又一次录音。我用Manglish说，马来西亚皮钦语。我从没想过这会在广播里播。
How come you never say anything when she beat me?
为什么你妈妈打我的时候你从没说过什么？
You say anything, who suffer? Your father.
你说什么，谁吃苦？你父亲。
She's saying if they said anything, who would suffer? Your father would.
她说如果我们说什么，谁会吃苦？你父亲。
So what about me suffer?
那关于我吃苦呢？
Huh?
嗯？
What about me suffer?
关于我吃苦呢？
You, you suffer? If we say, don't do that, she would done more.
你，你吃苦？如果我们说，别那样做，她会做得更多。
You suffer. If you say don't do that, she'll do more.
你吃苦。如果你说别那样做，她会做更多。
She'll beat more.
她会打得更多。
Not to say it stop. You thinking like that?
不是说它会停止。你那样想吗？
Not to say it'll stop. You think it's like that? Meaning, your mom didn't stop when we said something. You think it's that simple?
不是说它会停止。你认为就是那样吗？意思是，你妈妈没在我们说点什么时就停止。你认为就是那么简单吗？
Then Auntie told me this story about how once when I was little I woke up scared in the middle of the night and walked into her room. She woke up and whispered reassurances and ushered me back into bed as quickly and quietly as she could. She was terrified the entire time.
然后阿姨给我讲了一个故事，说有一次我小时候，半夜被吓醒了，走进她的房间。她醒了过来，耳语着安抚我，尽可能快且安静地把我送回床上。她整个过程都吓坏了。
She said she believed if my mom found out that I got up in the middle of the night, she'd hurt me. So Auntie did not dare wake her up or tell her what happened.
她说她相信如果我妈妈发现我半夜起来，她会伤害我。所以阿姨不敢叫醒她或者告诉她发生了什么。
It's unfair. Life is like that.
这不公平。生活就是那样。
Yeah, I know. Life is not fair, huh?
是的，我知道。生活是不公平的，哈？
All that fawning, those compliments-- Auntie told me they were only in part for me. My family indulged me with that immense display of kindness to show my mom how I deserved to be loved. It didn't work, but I'm still grateful.
所有的那些奉承，那些称赞——阿姨告诉我它们有一部分只是为了我。我的家人用那种巨大的友善表现来宠爱我，以向我妈妈展示我值得被爱。它没起作用，但我仍然感激。
Because sure, it was a lie. I wasn't the favorite. But the truth was better than the lie. For years, I thought nobody got it, that nobody was on my side. But they were. Auntie was.
因为当然，那是一个谎言。我不是最受宠的。但真相胜过谎言。多年来，我以为没人懂，没人站在我这边。但他们站在了。阿姨站在了。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program.
斯蒂芬妮·傅是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "KEPT IN THE DARK" BY ZACHARY THOMAS DIEDRICH]
[音乐 - 扎卡里·托马斯·迪德里希的《保持在黑暗中》]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Editing help from Joel Lovell, production help from Simon Adler.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，佐伊·查斯、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。乔尔·洛弗尔提供编辑帮助，西蒙·阿德勒提供制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的办公室经理。埃尔娜·贝克为我们的节目搜寻故事。米歇尔·哈里斯和克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉今天提供研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This is our last program with Adrianne Mathiowetz. For eight years, Adrianne has been the one who has been running our website, which means a lot of things, including emailing with thousands and thousands of you. When you right to us, you are usually first emailing with her. And if you have done that over the years, you know that she is lovely and level-headed and smart and just great.
这是我们与阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨的最后一个节目。八年来，阿德里安娜一直是我们网站的运营者，这意味着很多事情，包括回复你们成千上万的电子邮件。当你联系我们时，你通常是先联系她。如果你这些年来做过这些，你就知道她可爱、冷静、聪明，简直太棒了。
We will miss her. She has always been a part-time photographer and now she's becoming a full-time one. She is available for your freelance gigs, by the way. We wish her the best.
我们会想念她。她一直是一名兼职摄影师，现在她将成为一名全职摄影师。顺便说一句，她可以接自由职业工作。我们祝她一切顺利。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always, to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Matatia. On vacation this year, he tried to go to Disney World but ended up at Sea World.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马塔蒂亚先生。今年度假时，他试图去迪士尼世界，但最后去了海洋世界。
I was in the wrong world. That's what it felt like.
我在错误的世界里。那是我的感觉。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。